right it's it's again not just a lean
back i want to watch content but they
want to make that connection
um they they want to com they want to
connect with people who have similar
interests
and so when you watch a lot of streams
um especially those that have been
growing over time it's really kind of
the same group of people it's almost
like a group of friends coming and
enjoying talking with each other on chat
but also
talking with talking with the content
creators and i think that's why
they want they want that passion they
want that community they want that sort
of
being with like-minded people it's
almost like they're they're watching
content or enjoying an experience with
their squad
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
we have mike aragon who is the senior
vice president
at content at twitch mike i'm bummed
that you can't visit our office because
gary's got a really cool twitch studio
outside his office mike oversees the
company's global broadcaster
partnerships esports twitch studios
content development and marketing
uh prior to being at twitch he was at
elation and playstation during his eight
years at sony
he managed playstations network digital
video music and content services
and for consumers in more than 30
countries i'm sure dubai
or hailed from was one of them mike
welcome to the show and
uh you know great to see twitch and
everything it's doing in the industry
we're excited to have you on today
yeah thanks so much for having me i
appreciate it so mike
i think um you know it's probably for
the audience that's watching
uh twitch is a brand that they've heard
of at this point
or you know but may not know as much so
why don't we just start with the
hardcore twitch 101
i just want to make sure we ground
everybody even though it's one of the
leading
brands and platforms in the space and
thank you for being on brother yeah no
thanks again
good to see you gary um well yeah back
in 2017 when i joined twitch
uh it was i had to certainly explain to
a lot of people what twitch was
especially my my mom and my
my dad i didn't quite get it today we
are a lot more mainstream but i do think
that there's still some folks who
you know i've heard about it or kids
have heard about it
um or they've heard about it through
their kids but at twitch
we describe ourselves as a leading
service and community for multi-player
entertainment
and the way we describe multi-player
entertainment really is about
live interactive video and then the
shared experiences that happen with
the community and millions of people
around the world so you know
the way we think about twitch is it's
not a lean back
experience we're just kind of leaning
back and consuming content it really is
a lean forward experience
whether you're leaning in and engaging
with a community around your favorite
game
streamer or you're watching thursday
night football with your favorite fans
or your favorite streamer
um but it's that leaning experience that
really happens because people are uh
watching content and sharing this
passion with other people uh
that have similar tastes um they do this
a lot
um in chat on twitch so chat is the
conduit that connects
the content creators and the content and
the fans and you know a lot of
other services obviously have chat as
well i think that the difference on
twitch though is there really is a
dialogue that happens between the
community
each other and also the community and
the fans and so
it's that so we really see ourselves as
a as a video platform but it really is a
community that brings people together
um you know twitch right now we are
mostly game content so people watching
other people play video games or
watching esports
uh but if you think about the mechanism
for people
wanting live content having those
real-time interactive experiences that
gaming provides
it really has started to extend into a
lot of new categories sports
music or big ones just chatting which
gary i noticed that you you were uh
streaming
the other day and just chatting is uh
you know when i got here it was
almost non-existent in four years it's
now definitely a
top two sometimes it's not the number
one category but it's just a huge
category of people like you
streaming your passion or you know we've
got people doing talk shows we've got
people doing
um all kinds of different things uh that
communities are interested in
um and that has been a part of twitch
that has been growing and it's been
it's been quite phenomenal to see
you know actually you touched on where i
wanted to go but i want you to expand on
like why do you think people are
watching twitch like what's what's like
what are some of the themes and go a
little bit deeper on them
yeah well i think you know especially
today
uh in in this world where people are
still sheltering in place but even
before that
you know what we have found is that
twitch is a place where people want to
connect with
the community right it's it's again not
just a lean back i want to watch content
but they want to make that connection
um they they want to com they want to
connect with people who have similar
interests
and so when you watch a lot of streams
um especially those that have been
growing over time it's really kind of
the same group of people it's almost
like a group of friends coming and
enjoying talking with each other on chat
but also
talking with talking with the content
creators and i think that's why
they want they want that passion they
want that community they want that sort
of
being with like-minded people it's
almost like they're they're watching
content or enjoying an experience with
their squad
we sort of think of it as like virtual
party like people are on they just want
to go hang out with somebody and that's
kind of the experience
then we also have another subset of
folks who just love watching people
do what they do the best the best in the
world you know my daughter
got a 17 year old daughter who plays
soccer and she loves to watch rose level
soccer videos and leo messi videos and
some people who just want to watch
shroud
one of the best gamers in the world just
do his thing and see how this guy is so
amazing
um because he is and these some of these
folks are just the best in their world
and others are just
funny and entertaining and others are
you know they have so they've got all
kinds of different people we've got the
high skilled gamers we've got the gamers
who just have a great personality and
build community and and then we got some
folks who just want to learn from the
best
um but it really is about that community
and the connection with each other that
that makes twitch very very unique in
everything that we do actually michael
from my
for my own curiosity what what were you
doing right before twitch and what kind
of like
triggered you to to make the jump i'm
just there's a lot of executives
watching right now and i think you might
be able to help them with that and i
think that might be an interesting
question
yeah so to take a little bit of a a step
back
when i was um so you know i born and
raised in albuquerque new mexico
spent all my life there um you know my
parents were you know my dad worked for
the phone company middle grade middle
class family
um but you know didn't have a ton of
perspective out
outside of you know albuquerque we had
traveled a bit and my first job was at
intel
and um because intel at the time in
albuquerque was a
huge manufacturing facility i went and
worked there and kind of got into the
tech space first
um but decided you know that wasn't
quite my thing i wanted to go get my mba
and when i was coming out of my mba got
in the digi i worked for
uh booz allen at the time had a big
communication media technology
firm michael wolff who i'm sure you've
heard of was
an offer partner and worked for him
because they wanted they were
at the time the the sales pitch was the
convergence of media and technology
so i worked with him on a and other
partners on a bunch of you know projects
in that space where media companies were
starting to think about digital and what
the impact was going to be
we decided to move out in new york when
we had our twins and just said hey we
want to live a little bit closer to
albuquerque and
or home and that ended up being los
angeles and worked at a
studio for a bit at sony pictures and
helped them with a lot of their initial
digital transformation because this is
2004 2005 and
you know the studios were trying to
figure this out
um right around that time playstation 2
had was
uh sort of you know they were
deprecating playstation 2
launching playstation 3 and one of the
big gaps was we didn't have a very good
platform
a playstation platform and so they hired
a whole group of us to go
think about what's the business model
for playstation network and how do we
build experiences digital experiences
for games and online games and community
playing but also
other things like media and so i went
and i did that for a few years and
that's that's how i got into gaming
got it but my role at playstation was
really about gaming is at our core but
like what are other adjacent things that
gamers want to do they want to watch
netflix they want to watch
movies they want to listen to music and
so my job is running
those services and really thinking about
the adjacent interests of a gamer and
bringing that to playstation
and that helped playstation 4 get back
to where it was which was number one and
at the time i had uh met peter chernin
and his crew and
decided to to to do a stint in the the
sort of the startup world
and one of the things that peter was
trying to do is they had bought a an
asset called country roll which i'm sure
you're familiar with
back in 2015-ish you know and
crunchyroll's still quite popular it's
you know
very niche but it's one of the most
popular and
sort of dedicated services for people
who want to watch anime
but the thesis at churning at the time
was anime was great um
and had millions of subs i think it was
the top eight uh or the number eight
uh subscription service at the time kind
of behind mlb and netflix and others
but uh we all knew that there were sort
of diminishing returns in terms of the
audience just because it was niche and
so
one of the things that i had always been
able to do well in my past jobs was
figure out okay what is this based
business and how do you expand by
bringing adjacent content or adjacent
services
to make it bigger and so the thesis was
can we take
these several million country role
subscribers who love anime
add content that's adjacent to anime
sci-fi
and adult you know animation and other
things uh and really expand the base of
of of uh the audience there um and so
did that and ended up the company ended
up selling to a t
and you know they're they're all doing
great but at that point i had met emmett
scheer who's our ceo and kevin lynn
who's one of our founders
and they had this is i think maybe a
year and a half after
amazon uh had purchased them and you
know they they were under a little bit
of pressure to do the same thing you
know gaming is always going to be the
core of what we do but we know gamers
have a lot of adjacent interests and a
lot of different things
and so they wanted somebody with my
experience to be able to take
that uh take the service and really
expand without losing the essence and
the core of
of who we were which is gaming but to
try to bring in that the
the new type of content and also map lay
out a sort of a strategy a content
strategy so that we can do things
in a very twitch unique way which is
really around the interactivity of
bringing the community in and
um and so that's kind of sort of sort of
the quick
three-minute version of how i got to
where where i am at twitch
talk to me about the creators
yeah so well we've got uh gosh it's
grown
immensely since i've been there in my
four short years but we've got about
four million creators at any given point
in a month that stream on twitch right
now a majority of them are
our game streamers so they're playing
video games and they're broadcast
broadcasting it and interacting with
their fans
um but the creators have started to you
know as with any community
there's a lot of organic growth that
happens on these communities and so
we've had
just chatting pop-ups all of a sudden we
just have people wanting to talk about
politics and sports and music and a
bunch of other things
we had people start to stream cooking
streams because they were passionate
about it
one of the really funny experiments that
we did early on is we said hey what do
we
what if we start airing bob ross and
people are like god bob ross it's just
so
kind of random right like 1970s painter
but
the thing that resonated with bob ross
and why he was so popular on twitch is i
think he was the first person
who at skate or you know broadcast to
many many thousands or millions of fans
his passion his passion was painting
and a lot of twitch people kind of saw
that they're like well i have this
passion for gaming and i kind of see
this guy's passion and
that's why bob ross resonated on twitch
and continues to resonate today and so
um those the streamers are a pretty
diverse group of folks i mean we've got
when you think about the premium
streamers we've got a lot of uh we've
got deals with the nba and the nfl
really big content so those are content
creators we've got deals with media
companies
and then we've got deals with just a
whole slew of creators who sometimes
they just play video games sometimes
they do a mix of different things
we've got creators who are doing cooking
shows we've got fitness shows now
it's literally just grown into so many
different things that you would think
that
where creators want to create content
and share it with their fans and
and that's the basic creators right now
it's hard to kind of wrap it all up into
one because when you've got millions of
creators
there's a lot of different things that
are happening on twitch but those are
sort of the big
buckets of categories that are growing
on twitch right now
hey gary i'm just going to chime in and
ask a question mike
you know obviously with covet happening
watch time on on twitch is
is is up tremendously but it's so
entertaining like i've been on there
myself
and i just wanted to ask like for the
brands that are listening today like
what's the best way for them to
be part of an authentic experience so
that the the
you can preserve the the entertaining
way that people like to interact with
twitch
yeah i mean there's a we love there's a
lot of brands who have been joining
twitch and i think you know
uh one of the things that we've done is
we've built a lot of oh and oh
property so i have a i run a team called
twitch rivals which is basically an
esports tournament platform and
a lot of brands have wanted to attach to
that because esports is becoming
is growing and big and we can you know
we have a lot of great streamers who
participate in it
um but i think it's just like the when
bran you know we have a very
young engaged audience and 39 of our
uh the people on our service you know
don't have access to traditional tv i
mean
they're watching pretty much everything
online and so
there's a just a huge base of folks that
you know these brands can reach on
twitch but that that they can't reach
anywhere else
um but you know i would say that we've
just you know even if you think
uh that gaming is is like all we do it
really isn't there's so many other
different
really interesting different types of
content that um
people are engaging with and that are
that that's brand safe and that
um we think would be a great opportunity
for them to to tap into an audience that
they're not going to be able to reach
anywhere else
and how have the numbers been in covid
what what what can you share with us
about
i mean just we know the numbers are the
numbers but like what what what trends
have you seen and how do you think it's
going to sustain
yeah so um gosh you know we have grown
immensely
since since the covid uh thing hit i
think we
you know we're up to now four million
unique streamers every month
um in q1 we had 79 million daily active
viewers which is a lot more than last
year
we've got about a million and a half
people that are tuning into twitch on
average um
and it's growing significantly from
there so if you just look at general tv
i mean we'd be a top three cable net
just uh just if you think about scale of
where we're at
um you know and i think with kovid it it
what has happened is we've seen a
massive increase in streamers
um but it's also musicians who can't
tour you know one of the great things
about which is like now i can go and i
can connect with fans that i couldn't
before and so we've seen a massive
influx there
athletes looking to stay engaged and
connecting with our fans has been
been a huge thing we had one of the
things that happened really early on
that i thought was really kind of fun
was we had some of the f1 drivers lando
norris charles leclerc and they were
like
god what are we going to do we can't
race so they were running sims and then
they started running their sims on
twitch
and now you've got like lando norris
who's
pulling in 20 30 000 concurrents just
watching him run his sims
and now he loves it because now he's got
fans and now these fans are becoming
you know huge lando norris fans because
they love this guy he's got a great
personality
super cool kid he's a winner and
now while he's not being able to fully
train all the time but he can actually
train on his sim and actually do two
things at once which is
continue to build that fan paste that
fan base of lando norris fans
um so we've seen a lot of that that that
different activity um
across the board um you know another fun
thing that happened kind of early
on was you know devin booker was
streaming i think he's probably
streaming at call of duty and then
some somebody tweeted at him one of his
teammates hey i think we're on hiatus
and then
it you know diverted into this 30 minute
what's happening are we canceling the
stream
and all this stuff is happening on
twitch and so it's just it's hard to
pinpoint
exactly what's happening because you've
got millions of streams but there's just
so many of these different types of
moments that have been happening
it seems like there's been more cultural
you know whether it was way back kind of
the moment with
you know drake and juju and ninja you
know like like it's
it does seem like things happen on
twitch like cultural moments things that
hit the zeitgeist things that are talked
about
yeah yeah i think people are starting to
see that more i mean i think another one
of those gary was
you know i'm going to screw up his name
how poor bjorn's in the the mountain
from yeah
he was like you know what i think i'm
going to try to break the world deadlift
record on twitch
so he does it and it's just like another
one of those moments where it's like
god that's it's amazing you can't script
those things but
people do that because he wanted to
break that record with his fans and be
able to
share that with them and and he did it
um so yeah you're right gary it's at
zeitgeist it's that moment and
and it's a great place for people to do
things with that that are
interesting for their for their
communities here's an important question
do your parents now understand what
you're up to
sort of my mom my mom still says i work
for amazon
so it's easier for her
and it just carries a little bit more
cashier i get it
we let it we let her we let it slide but
yeah i think she looks at this stuff and
she's like
i don't understand this video game thing
but it's okay you know it's like
she gets it and she knows that we're
happy and that things are growing and
that you know i work for a company
that's that's a it's a wonderful company
um and she's super proud of it so yeah
they they're getting it a little bit
more but it's still a little bit like
really they're watching people play
video games
i mean by the way that argument has been
the silliest and easiest argument for me
to win within three seconds
gary they're watching other people play
video games i'm like
like you watch people play golf yeah
like this notion
that like watching somebody else i think
it's stupid to have somebody else
watch somebody else doing something i'm
like you mean every sport
yeah exactly and the thing is is if you
look back
okay so i was in college in the 90s you
know and swingers was a big movie i
don't know one of them yes of course
they're playing you know and it's hell
94 yeah i remember
my my friends you know we used to sit
and we used to sit in somebody's room
and we would play goal
and we'd be fighting with each other and
that's we would do that for hours and
we'd have like you know
you know girlfriends would come over and
we'd all just be sitting in this room
and we'd just switch off and we
talked a lot of smack with each other
but that's been going on since the 90s
when none of this stuff was connected
and so like
yeah it seems foreign to some folks but
like the nature of video games is it's a
communal thing it's a fun thing
it is a way to connect with your friends
with fans and so yeah it's it's
it's definitely not actually on that on
that no mike
what what video game because ironically
you just brought up
if somebody asked what game
would i feel most confident
that i can compete at the highest level
meaning there is no game on earth that
i'm even in the top
you know half a million best players in
the world it's just not what i was meant
to do
but if but if i had to play the game it
would probably be
nhl 94 yeah street fighter
with blanca i've got this thing down
with blanca that's
funny okay well ironically i think it's
hockey games for me or ironically
ice hockey for nintendo but for you
what would you say like the single game
that you would argue
whether you're good or not good like i
am at video games
is your strongest game and you would put
up the best record
up with that's a tough one
um i uh well i'm older
gary so i work with a lot of you know 20
30 year olds in there
the hand eye coordination the twitch
quick twitch element this is like yeah
but you might but you might be
unstoppable at like fishing derby for
atari
i'm pretty good at the old school game
i'm pretty i'm really good at goal
on nintendo i'm good at like the yeah
i'm good at most of the sports games
like the early early early sports games
yeah like rbi baseball or like baseball
for nintendo
baseball and and the middle the early
maddens was my thing
um do you remember rinking i was very
good at bringing
i do remember me ring king um the game
the current game that i'm actually
not bad at um is fall guys so fall guys
might need to
talk about that fall guys might be the
you know
we're hoping it might be the you know
the 2020 version of of fortnite or other
big games it's uh this massive
multiplayer game
60 players totally fun you know you go
through a series of obstacles and it's
the last character standing
uh we just did a rival sermon so my team
runs these rivals tournaments
um and it was the very first fall guy
tournament we had like
pretty much every single one of our big
creators playing
and it was like sixty five thousand six
hundred and fifty thousand people
watching on friday
this tournament and we didn't even give
a big prize pool because we were like
trying to pull it together it was just
plastic it was like it was like seven
thousand bucks but you got people like
you know some of our top streamers are
making a lot of money and they're
fighting over this
you know for them you know seven
thousand dollars a lot of money for most
people but for them you know it's it's
it's a modest prize pool in the esports
world but man they were so excited about
it and it's just a fun game and it and
it's one of those ones where
pride is worth a billion dollars exactly
exactly so we're bragging rights as well
right right right mike thank you so much
for joining us we will be
watching more twitch so we can get more
entertained and and really
engage with some of the gamers and
streamers we appreciate your time today
oh yeah perfect yeah thanks for having
me guys thank you this was fun
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out